soir katia le chemin choisi par le
gouvernement est il toujours tenable
en clair à quoi doit-on s'attendre ces
prochains jours il vient écouter
stéphanie pour le moment on avance
toujours à tâtons mais il n'y aura pas
encore de tour de vis supplémentaire
eh bien il n'y a pas de nouvelles
restrictions en tout cas cette semaine
gabriel attal a assuré qu'un troisième
confinement n'était pas n'était pas une
fatalité il s'est exprimé comme vous le
disiez à l'issue du conseil des
ministres et du conseil de défense qui
ont lieu ce matin
alors il faut tout d'abord attendre les
faits des mesures annoncées par jean
castex la semaine dernière à savoir la
fermeture des frontières avec des pays
hors de l'union européenne
la fermeture des grands centres
commerciaux et puis le renforcement des
contrôles des contrôles de couvre feu
par les forces de l'ordre
et puis il faut aussi ajouter que
emmanuel macron a tracé une voie c'est à
dire à garder le pays le plus ouvert
possible malgré le virus tout proposé
d'écouter gabriélat talent au sujet du
confinement
nous sommes aujourd'hui engagés dans une
mobilisation qui est une mobilisation
nationale pour éviter un confinement
j'ai dit à l'instant que faudrait
toujours les mesures nécessaires quand
elles sont nécessaires pour protéger
notre système de santé pour protéger
l'hôpital et pour protéger la santé des
français mais vous le savez le
confinement pour nous est une mesure
ultime recours
quand nous avons tout essayé est ce que
nous portons aujourd'hui collectivement
c'est une mobilisation nationale
supplémentaires pour tenir ensemble face
à l'épidémie
et pour faire reculer l'épidémie et saas
est entre nos mains
a tous je le disais à l'instant avec les
gestes barrière avec le recours au
télétravail et avec les politique qui
est menée par le gouvernement notamment
sur le tester alerté protéger alors
concrètement il n'y a pas d'explosion
des contaminations mais malheureusement
pas d'amélioration non plus nous nous
trouvons sur un plateau mais
malheureusement aussi les variants
progressent alors le porte-parole du
gouvernement a insisté sur l'importance
du télétravail il a appelé les
à limiter tout contact et puis gabella
talent a également annoncé que 1.5
millions de français avaient été
vaccinés
mais pour en savoir plus sur la campagne
de vaccination il faudra attendre demain
l'intervention de jean castex le premier
ministre et olivier ferrand en
conférence de presse
et nous attendrons sa 4 s'est appliqué
nous le suivrons donc devoir merci à
vous d'avoir été en direct depuis
l'elysée